bonsoir bonsoir
alors je ne sais pas si j'aurai un guide
ou un manuel pour le cerveau c'est
quelque chose quand même d'assez
complexe 1 et c'est une bonne chose
c'est l'organe le plus complexe qu'on
connaisse et c'est le seul organe qui
s'est nommé lui-même
donc respect pour le cerveau moi ça fait
dix ans que je suis chercheur en
neurosciences et je suis psychologue et
j'ai encore un peu de mal avec le guide
et donc il faut respecter je pense cette
complexité
aujourd'hui je vous parlais de nos
pensées on vient de découper un très
joli toc sur les sur l'éducation il faut
pouvoir apprendre à apprendre mais il
faut aussi savoir réfléchir à notre
réflexion et c'est de ça aujourd'hui que
je vous parlais je vais essayer de vous
emmener un peu sur plusieurs aspects de
notre décision de notre raisonnement de
comment est-ce que notre cerveau des
fois se font un peu de notre gueule pour
notre propre bien mais pour faire ça il
faut qu'on parle de quelques concepts
avant pour y arriver
si vous prenez par exemple le monde
physique dans le monde physique tout le
monde c'est une action cause une
réaction
en gros si par exemple je prends ma
bague l'action de la lâcher fait qu'elle
tombe dans ma main à cause de la gravité
une action qu une réaction je suis en la
vague de la balance sur ma tête
l'action on va faire une réaction je
vais avoir mal tu es probablement avoir
l'air super on va essayer de l'éviter
par contre dans le cerveau c'est un peu
différent on dit souvent qu'on voit avec
les yeux qu'on entend avec les oreilles
qu'on touche avec une autre peau mais en
fait c'est pas vraiment vrai on fait
tout ça avec notre cerveau nos yeux nous
aurait notre peau sont juste des
récepteurs qui transmettent
l'information du monde extérieur à notre
centre de traitement de l'information
qui est notre cerveau qui va décider du
réaction donc si on regarde le cerveau
dans le cerveau c'est plutôt une action
qui passe par un filtre et ce filtre qui
est notre cerveau va analyser ces choses
et causé une certaine réaction
sauf que dans ce filtre il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'informations qui arrivent et
donc
il doit prendre des décisions dès fois
assez rapide j'avais vu avec mon
collègue qui lui a parlé d' intelligence
artificielle qui a une façon de résoudre
des problèmes on peut résoudre des
problèmes avec une méthode comme la
méthode scientifique donc on va faire
des observations faire une théorie après
fer des lames de la modélisation
c'est une façon précise de faire les
choses c'est grâce à ça qu'on peut
construire des ordinateurs qu'on peut
envoyer des satellites en orbite etc
mais dans la vie de tous les jours c'est
un peu difficile de faire ce processus à
chaque fois qu'on doit prendre une
décision
du coup notre cerveau de filtres qui
traitent ces informations il utilise une
autre technique une technique
approximative qui marche à peu près bien
on appelle cette façon de résultats les
solutions d eau ristic et notre cerveau
c'est une sorte d'organe qui utilisent
des heuristiques pour arriver à la
certaines solutions les eaux ristic
c'est quelque chose qui marche en
général très bien mon collègue qui a
parlé de l'indigent des filles elle a
aussi mentionné les éristique c'est
quand il a dit par exemple que vous
pouvez conduire et vous avez à peu près
des chances d'arriver à destination
du coup la majorité du temps nos
services tic marche très bien si on
regarde un exemple par exemple de ristic
si vous regardez cette photo
la personne qui lance le disque est la
personne qui attrape le disque sont en
train de faire des heuristiques la
personne qui lance le disque n'est pas
en train de calculer la trajectoire du
disque la force du lancer la pression
atmosphérique pour savoir visé
exactement le titre a enfin arrivé la
même manière la personne qui reçoit ne
voit pas le disque voler son cerveau
fait des calculs de trajectoire de
tangente de sinus et de cosinus et se
place un endroit il dit le disque va
arriver là probablement ces personnes
ont jeté des frisbee à succession
plusieurs plusieurs fois et ces mots de
leur modèle heuristique se sont
améliorées et ils deviennent de mieux
meilleur à faire cette chose c'est très
important de comprendre que c'est aux
risques sont hyper importants pour notre
fonctionnement on peut pas fonctionner
sans nous est restée ces mesures ici qui
me permettre qui me permette de serrer
la main à quelqu'un on ne calcule pas la
vitesse d'aproz comme un avion
on juste on serre la main et la majorité
du temps notre cerveau est très sympa il
nous rend complètement aveugle à ces
choses sauf que des fois ils se trompent
des fois on n'arrive pas à attraper de
disques des fois je marchais mois un
espace que j'ai déjà navigué plein plein
plein de fois et je prends la porte
comme si mon cerveau a oublié les
limites de mon corps des fois j'arrive
pas à viser ma bouche dans certaines
circonstances douteuses et vous pouvez
voir que les enfants il n'y arrive pas
vraiment on peut voir le modèle ristic
s'améliorer jusqu'à ce qu'ils y arrivent
à peu près à 99.9 % et du coup si le
récit qu'on les utilise dans notre
comportement on les utilise dans nos
sports mais aussi on les utilise dans
notre raisonnement et c'est un peu donc
une grande partie du temps ça marche
très bien mais aujourd'hui c'est pas
sympa on va parler des fois où ça marche
pas très bien on va parler des erreurs
qui peuvent se passer dans notre
raisonnement dans nos décisions
on appelle ça des biais cognitifs ou d
erreur de logique qui peuvent toucher
notre raisonnement et pour faire ça j'ai
une petite expérience que je partage
avec vous invite vous poser des
questions c'est une question très simple
vous est la couleur de certains éléments
que je vais montrer à l'écran c'est très
important que toutes les personnes qui
veulent participer répondre très vite il
faut juste répondre vite la couleur il
n'y a pas de piège
il n'y a pas des nuances de couleurs
juste dit la couleur que vous voyez il
ya probablement des personnes qui
connaissent déjà cette expérience c'est
pas grave c'est très important que vous
participiez aussi et du coup on va y
aller c'est très simple vous allez juste
répondre et je vais faire défiler des
images donc la première image quelle est
la couleur de ce nuage très bien quelle
est la couleur de ses failles quelle est
la couleur de ce carré quelle est la
couleur de cette tasse super quelle est
la couleur de cette diapos que bois la
vache
très bien du lait sauf que si vous
regardez moi j'ai pas encore vu des
rivières de l'est je passe ça existe
quelque part mais en général les vaches
ça boit de l'eau ce qui s'est passé
c'est un peu comme un jeu de pyramide
rapide qu'on a fait si vous le dit blanc
les pardons blanc liquider vaches
automatiquement vos os ristic vont
arriver à la conclusion les pour ceux
qui connaissent déjà mais qui ont réussi
à dire oh si vous avez fait attention
ils sont un peu plus lent parce qu'il le
mollet apparaît automatiquement il faut
qu'on lit ni pour donner la bonne
réponse pour tous ceux qui ont dit lei
ça veut dire que votre cerveau
fonctionne bien donc je déjà pour
rassurer
c'est ça qui fait que vous pouvez
vraiment fonctionner sinon ce serait
beaucoup trop compliqué tout le temps
inhibé et on se prend la tête
donc certes certains chercheurs ont
théorisé qu'on a deux systèmes de pensée
un système plutôt rapide qu'on utilise
dans nos eaux ristic et un système plus
lent plus délibéré c'est important pour
moi de vous dire de partir sur une
petite vengeance
ça va être long c'est que ce genre
d'image c'est des métaphores
on n'a pas trouvé dans notre cerveau des
neurones lent et des neurones rapide
mais des fois les métaphores saeeda
accessibilité la connaissance tant qu'on
respecte la complexité c'est important
pour moi le deuxième point que je vais
faire n'a rien à voir avec ce dogme
c'est juste que cette image est divisée
en deux et donc ça peut faire penser
pour certaines personnes a un cerveau
gauche et un cerveau droit un cerveau
créatif c'est tout à fait faux ça
n'existe pas je vais profiter de
l'occasion aujourd'hui des personnes qui
ne regardent ici et ailleurs
il n'y a pas de cerveau gauche du
cerveau droit c'est vraiment un mythe et
on essaye vraiment dans sont débarrassés
donc j'en profite et du cou et du coup
on a métaphoriquement dépenses et rapide
des dépenses est lente certaine pensée
rapides peuvent se tromper comme ce
qu'on vient de voir mais ça veut pas
dire que nous penser landes sont tout à
fait rationnel
nos pensées vont aussi ont des pièges
nos pensées l'entente j'utilise souvent
dans nos décisions et du coup dans nos
prises de décisions des fois on peut
être biaisé on peut être rationnel le
problème de notre irrationalité en tant
qu'espèce seco n'est pas seulement
irrationnel où on peut être prédictible
le mans irrationnel mais rationnel de
façon constante
certaines personnes peuvent utiliser
cette irrationalité kona disons pour
nous manipuler un peu donc certains
chercheurs ont fait une recherche sur du
pop corn
parce que pourquoi donc ils ont posé
deux tailles de pop corn à vendre un peu
requinqué petit à 3 euros un grand pope
cognaçais taureau ils ont vu comment est
ce que les ventes fonctionnel et dans ce
cas là la majorité des personnes acheter
le petit corps considérant que le pop
corn avocat on a 7 euros c'est presque
de la relance et du coup ils vendaient
beaucoup plus le petit pot quand le
lendemain
les chercheurs ont introduit une
nouvelle option ils n'ont pas touché aux
petits pop corn pas toucher aux grands
pop corn pas toucher aux prix ils ont
introduit une option un pop corn moyens
à 6,50 et là la majorité des gens
commençaient à acheter le pop corn à 7
euros
le pop corn à 3 euros est soudainement
devenu trop petit ça vaut pas le coup
qui va acheter un petit peu comme le pop
corn moyens il est à 6,5 en autant payer
50 centimes en plus et acheter le grand
est du coup cet effet ça fait s'appelle
l'effet de cadrage en changeant le
cadrage dans certains éléments sans
toucher les valeurs ni la taille ni la
nature de l'objet
on peut changer les décisions en
apprenant en étant conscient de ces
différents billets mais si quelqu'un
peut nous manipuler ça veut dire que des
fois on peut se manipuler ce moi même
parce que pourquoi laisser le plaisir
aux autres
donc des fois
par exemple je vous donne un exemple
dans toutes les personnes qui font un
régime au lieu de juste compter les
calories ce que vous pouvez faire parce
que notre cerveau des fois on peut le
manipuler c'est d'utiliser des plats
plus petits si vous mettez la même
quantité de bouffe dans trois plats un
plat petit un plat moyens flagrant
la personne qui manque dans le crabe
grand plat aura tendance à avoir plus
faim que la personne qui mange dans le
plat petit puisqu'il ya tellement de
nourriture
georges puget pas pouvoir manger le même
truc c'est un peu comme la plaque de la
personne qui demande qui dit qu'elle
peut pas manger une pizza divisé en 8
mai à peut la manger s'il est divisé en
quatre c'est le même principe si
complètement irrationnel mais des fois
c'est comme ça donc on a vu jusque
jusqu'ici que on peut faire des erreurs
que notre raisonnement n'est pas tout à
fait un rationnel tout le temps
mais on est quand même dans l'analyse de
d2 la réalité dans le traitement de
l'information pour la deuxième partie je
vais vous parler de comment des fois on
peut complètement inventé un sens si il
ya quelque chose qu'on ne comprend pas
dans le monde
on invente un sens au lieu de dire on
sait pas on va inventer le sens de plus
commun et pour cela je ramenais aussi
une petite expérience avec moi qui
touche notre raisonnement je vais
montrer donc une image et dans général
ce qu'on dit c'est qu'il faut voir
quelque chose pour le croire dans notre
cerveau c'est plutôt le contraire on
pense qu'il faut plutôt le croire pour
le voir et donc je vais vous démontrer
cela et on en reparle juste après donc
il ya une danseuse qui tombe elle n'est
pas aussi belle que les danseuses qu'on
a fait ici mais vous me pardonnerez et
je veux juste c'est très simple je veux
que tout le monde regarde la danseuse
que les personnes qui voient la danseuse
tourner dans le sens contraire des
aiguilles d'une montre lave les mains
mais personne qui la voit tourner dans
le sens des aiguilles d'une montre
déjà il ya un problème on n'est pas en
train de voir la même chose mais ne vous
inquiétez pas je vais mettre tout le
monde d'accord
si elles ne changent pas et vous
l'approuvez pourtant tout le monde ma
cuisse tout le temps de changer mais
elle change pas si on regarde l'image
d'après si vous regardez à droite et
après au centre pour tout le monde
la danseuse du centre devrait maintenant
tourner dans le sens inverse des
aiguilles d'une montre pour garder
quelques secondes ici et a pris au
milieu pour tout le monde ça devrait
marcher si ça marche pas venu me voir je
serais intéressé pour savoir si on
recule on va dévoiler mais l'image ici
si vous regardez ici après au simple
pour tout le monde
elle va tourner dans le sens des
aiguilles d'une montre pour les
personnes qui disaient que je la change
on va faire la totale on va diviser les
deux si vous regardez ici
et puis au centre elle tourne dans le
sens contraire du bout du monde
si vous regardez ici et puis au centre
elle tombe dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre
si vous êtes vraiment bon vous pouvez
regarder ici ici ici ici elle va
commencer à faire une sorte de macarena
elle peut plus vraiment bougé c'est
important pour moi quand je monte ce
genre d'image d'expliquer comment ça
marche parce que comme je vous ai dit
les métaphores c'est très bien mais des
fois aussi simplifier un sujet complexe
ça nous aide pas ce qui se passe ici
c'est que cette image ça fait une
illusion bistable de côté et une vision
bi stable ce qui se passe c'est juste
que votre cerveau n'a pas de marqueurs
de profondeur donc votre cerveau ne sait
pas quand est-ce que là j'en passe
devant quand est-ce qu'elle passe
derrière
et du coup il attribue sa croyance à la
réalité
donc quand vous regardez ici on appelle
ça un a priori il va vous va porter la
priory perceptive qui le voit ici sur le
simili neutre et si vous regardez ici
votre cerveau va porter cet a priori sur
l'illusion bistable et la portée et la
voix et du coup perceptuelle mans on
voit pas la même chose donc si quelqu'un
à cette croyance donc ça c'est perceptif
ça marche à peu près pareil raisonnement
là encore c'est une métaphore c'est pas
vraiment comme ça que ça marche mais
sinon de tête devraient prendre
considérablement plus de temps en année
on sait pas vraiment encore de toute
façon si quelqu'un croit ça
une autre personne croit ça ils sont en
train de discuter de la réalité
c'est difficile de se mettre d'accord
quand on ne voit même pas la même chose
ce n'est plus une différence d'opinion
tout à l'heure mon collègue vous disais
qu'il a envoyé deux personnes dans un
endroit où il n'y avait pas de
chaussures et une personne est revenu en
disant un milliard n'a pas donc on peut
pas en vendre une personne qui a dit on
n'en a pas il y en a pas donc c'est un
énorme marché
imaginez que quelqu'un il envoie deux
personnes une personne revient lui dis à
tout le monde a des chaussures à leur
pied une autre personne revient lui dix
personnes notre chaussure à leur pied
du coup ça rend la communication
compliquaient donc ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui c'est que notre cerveau
reconstruit la réalité on voit les
choses plutôt tels que nous nous sommes
plutôt que tel que le monde et que des
fois notre pensée peuvent nous induire
en erreur
aussi bien en emprisonnement que dans
nos décisions
j'aurais aimé vous donner
des astuces pour éviter les biais
positif
j'aurais aimé vous donner des astuces
pour être sûr que vous voyez ce qui a
vraiment pour voir ce qu'il faut voir et
pas ceux qu'on croit
mais j'en ai pas parce que comme je vous
dis le cerveau est un organe très
complexe si je viens et je vous dis vous
pouvez changer au bout de 15 minutes
1 je suis en train de vous mentir et 2
c'est pas vraiment souhaitable parce
qu'il imaginait qu'on peut changer en
une semaine ou en deux semaines si on
était seuls c'est pas un problème mais
les humains nous sommes des êtres
sociaux
on a besoin d'interagir et donc on a
besoin d'une certaine stabilité si un
jour un je suis calme le lendemain je
suis colérique le troisième jour je suis
flemmard on vous auriez du mal à
communiquer avec moi et j'aurais du mal
à communiquer avec vous parce qu'on a
besoin de garder certains repères et
donc on ne peut pas vraiment changer
vite notre cerveau aussi une temporalité
différente de notre société
on est dans une société où c'est très
facile d'avoir ce qu'on appelle de la
gratification instantanée
je veux quelque chose je veux l'acheter
je lai j'ai faim je peux aller au sur
leurs chais je mange mais notre cerveau
est beaucoup plus lent ici une
temporalité plus lent in the wind en
pratique est plus complexe et donc je
sais que on peut vous promettre des fois
de libérer votre cerveau de débloquer
votre potentiel latent
malheureusement on ne peut pas vraiment
faire ça qu'à travers un travail long et
des fois difficile parce qu'on a besoin
de comprendre plein de choses et de
nuancer la réalité c'est beaucoup plus
simple d'écraser la réalité de
simplifier les choses de diviser le
monde de le polarisée et après de se
dire on a tout compris
mais notre cerveau qui fait le travail
pour nous qui nous convainc de nos
opinions déjà un
ça nous aide mais ça on perd en richesse
on perd en liant son père ce qui rend le
monde intéressant et du coup si j'avais
un conseil seulement pour vous donner ce
serait de doute et essayer de douter de
vos pensées essayez de douter de vos
émotions
essayez de douter de vos intuitions dit
tout le temps il faut se fier à ce nos
intuitions non si vos intuitions sont en
train de vous induire en erreur ou faut
douter de vos intuitions c'est de douter
du mollet quand il apparaît dans votre
tête et de ne pas automatiquement le
gérer
quand je vous dis
je disais que je travaille sur réfléchir
à notre réflexion c'est un peu quand
j'ai une idée qui me vient en tête quand
j'ai une émotion qui me viens dans mon
corps s'est créé une petite pause avant
d'agir dessus si vous voyez quelqu'un
que vous connaissez pas et vous sentez
que vous avez peur douter de cette pop
demandez vous est ce que cette peur est
réel ou est-ce que cette peur vient
d'ailleurs est ce que cette peur vient
d'un billet est ce que cette peur vient
d'une pensée trop rapide
si vous appelez votre conjoint ou votre
conjoint et qu'elle répond pas vous
dites est sûrement en train de me
tromper douter un peu
d'un tir bas de gamme du coup si vous
êtes intéressé par ce genre de questions
par prendre le temps par vous creuser un
peu la tête par des solutions qui sont
pas faciles mais qui respecte avec
respecte un peu la complexité des choses
j'ai créé avec trois amis chercheurs une
structure qui s'appelle khiasma vous
allez sur notre site qui anima point qu
aussi agi asm à point qu où on organise
des débats périodiques sur paris
gratuits ouverts à tout le monde où on
fait des débats et après on essaye de
détecter les arguments qui sous tend
notre raisonnement ce qu'on est
intéressé par pourquoi on forme un
raisonnement plutôt que par le
raisonnement lui même puisque si vous
êtes attaché à un raisonnement ou à une
opinion si vous êtes attaché à votre
opinion à un parti politique à un couple
a un boulot et qui a des nouvelles
informations qui arrivent qui vont
contre ces choses vous n'allez pas les
croire mais si vous êtes attachés au
processus
l'opinion n'est plus importante et on
peut développer ce qui s'appelle la
flexibilité mentale
donc si vous êtes intéressé je vous
invite à vous joindre à nous sinon
j'espère c'était quand même intéressant
et je vous remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]